we all totally asked for this movie we
needed this movie you know what all this
time for the past two years I've been
like where's right along - man I need
right along - anyone ever said that ever
yeah so right along - so right along to
is the sequel to the movie that limped
along because Kevin Hart Kevin his way
into the hearts of America and this guy
just cranks out movies man good movies
bad movies [ __ ] movies Kevin Hart Kevin
Hart it looked like the shake weight
sorry so in this movie Kevin Hart still
marrying Ice Cube sister Ice Cube still
doesn't like Kevin Hart but the two of
them go to Miami to do this just stop
batty she takes Kevin Hart there to
prove to Kevin Hart that Kevin Hart does
not have what it takes to be a cop
because now Kevin Hart himself is a cop
not a detective yet but you know he
wants to be to be fair I feel like ice
cube and Kevin Hart as human beings
probably have good chemistry I just
don't think their characters are written
to have good chemistry at all I get what
they're doing we're ice cubes the big
one like you don't have what it takes
and Kevin Hart's the little energetic
yeah yeah yeah yeah it is I know you
don't
oh that's comedy is like the two
Bulldogs in Looney tune but I was
watching it I was like Ice Cube is made
to be so unlikable in these movies
because he ultimately just bullies Kevin
Hart the entire time Ice Cube and Kevin
Hart in the ride-along movies are like
Harry and Marv in the home alone movie
Harry's really rough with Mara be smacks
him around always tells him he's no good
and as that works for home alone and
this one a little bit goes a long way
you should have that in right along but
you should actually sprinkle in some
good in there when Kevin Hart's like I'm
gonna lose my job and Ice Cube's like I
don't care you just don't really feel
like there is any friendship you're
really fighting for it here because he's
not fighting for it so why should you
care if he doesn't care they need to
show that he actually does care he just
hides he's kind of an [ __ ] with a
heart of gold [ __ ] I get heart of
gold I don't say it and Kevin Hart at
this point I feel like Kevin Hart has
run into what every comedic actor runs
into it's like Melissa McCarthy Melissa
McCarthy is the same in everything but
not opposed to Kevin Hart being the same
Kevin Hart we all know and making good
movie I'm just saying at this point is
kind of boring Jim Carrey ran into that
in the 90s it's the same thing he's
Kevin Hart Bing Kevin Hart because Kevin
Hart and these would only be annoyances
if the movie was good has just had these
little Christ's but
in the end the movies just it just takes
all of its beats from every subpar
buddy-cop movie that has ever come
before it
nothing is memorable in this movie it's
why I have to hammer out this review
quickly I'm gonna forget it by tomorrow
there were some scenes that made me
chuckle and/or entertain me there's a
pretty good foot chase scene in this
movie probably because of the music the
music that played during this chase it's
a surprisingly good foot chase off but
those moments are too few and far
between for a movie where you like I've
seen this before this is taking all of
its beats from the first movie but not
the ones that should be taking I mean
there were more than a few moments where
the comedy was awkward in this movie is
a scene where they have guns drawn on
this guy and they're you know asking
questions to tell him drop is going
Kevin Hart gets spooked and he shoots
the guy in the chest the whole vibe in
the room is like oh man what did you
it's like well I didn't know oh my god I
got new I should have left you at home
didn't the guy sits up because he has a
bulletproof vest on but they didn't know
he had a bulletproof vest on IceCube
while he's being look I should have just
left you at home dog gonnit thanks Kevin
hard straight-up shot this dude in the
chest and killed him I think they
probably should have had Kevin Hart
shoot him in the foot that way the whole
luck I should have left you at home we'd
be justified because it is a flesh wound
there's just one scene where Kevin Hart
gets behind the wheel and Kevin Hart
plays a lot of Grand Theft Auto and he
was like all I can do this and then it
shows what he sees and the world turns
into a Grand Theft Auto video game
looking thing and then he's driving like
he's in Grand Theft Auto and it keeps
flashing back to it being a video game
then flashes back to real life and it
shows it as a video game again it was
weird and I think it was unnecessary I
mean you can see it changed the one time
and then you kind of get oh he's
thinking Grand Theft Auto and then show
him driving that's all you need to see
it doesn't take much to know that this
guy is kind of associating his driving
to his video game driving remember that
movie Darrell there's a movie called
Darrell and this kid is really good at
pole position and then there's this
chase scene where he's like I can do
this I've done it before
and then he just Bob's and weaves in
between these cars and you immediately
assess you're like oh he's playing
popo's a sheen in his mind the world
never changed into a video game or
anything you just knew he was playing
pole position in his head was not
necessary to change the rule into a
video game for the audience to make that
connection and just came across as
awkward in this movie guys in the end
right along to is a sequel I can say
that it's not a sequel we needed and
it's not one we're going to care about
the Kevin Hart sticks kind of gettin old
at this point Ice Cube I want to like
Ice Cube in these movies but I just
don't I already said it I had to hammer
out this review really quickly because
I'm not going to
this movie in t-minus one day and
neither will you
I already forgot I so right along - have
you seen it what did you think about it
but every thought comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more